mais je vous présente christian charpy
turini qui a un ex néo nazis et qui
depuis s'est des convertis et cherche à
les convertir d'autres personnes du
mouvement
il a publié récemment un livre qui
s'appelle paul kingate et l'espace de
très peu de temps c'est un peu devenu
espèce de d'exemple à suivre pour moi en
tout cas sur l'art en particulier de
mieux débattre
son histoire est vraiment absolument
incroyable et vous recommande vivement
de que vous allez voir sa représentation
avec alix qui est grand fantastiques ou
encore son livre dans lequel il ya des
histoires assez assez assez folle qu'on
explique tristan pitt unis il a causé
des atrocités ignoble ce qui peut-être
intéressant à noter c'est que il ne
semblait pas conscients de l'atrocité de
ses actes au moment où les comités et je
pense que ça rejoint quelles choses
assez générales
on est très très sensible à
l'agressivité des autres mais on n'est
pas forcément très sensible à
l'agressivité de nos propres messages
tels qu'ils seront perçus par les
destinataires de ces messages
du coup je pense que d'enfants du recul
sur ses effets de nos propres
communications
c'est un exemple très très intéressant
m'activer sur sa maison bien plus
extrême que la plupart d'entre nous
mais si je vous parle de questions
piccini c'est pas pour vous parler de ça
c'est plus pour vous parler de son art
sa maîtrise à chaque débat tenu que je
trouve vraiment hallucinante
[Musique]
on commence à penser que à chaque bâton
mieux ça nécessite d'avoir des
interlocuteurs qui sont prêts aussi être
dans cet esprit pitié ni a vraiment le
cas extrêmes opposés tous les personnes
avec qui il interagit ce sont des
personnes extrêmement engagés dans leur
propre mouvement
et du coup quand vous parlez un néonazi
on voit quelqu'un de très radicaliser
bah c'est une question évidente que de
savoir quelle est la meilleure façon
d'interagir avec ces individus
particuliers quels sont les meilleurs
arguments
quelle est la rhétorique régulier c'est
la question qu'on se pose beaucoup et du
coup la grande question c'est quelle est
la méthode qu'utilise piccini bien la
france peut vous surprendre alors du
doigt une stade je trouve vraiment cela
fascinant selon piccini qui un taux de
succès ahurissant
on part n'importe qui d'autre la
meilleure façon de couvin c'est qu'ils
commencer par écouter et à résoudre les
problèmes les autres en particulier de
façon cruciale
la meilleure façon de convaincre c'est
de ne pas engager un débat d'idées en
tout cas pour commencer surtout pas au
début à l écoute écoute les coûts de
l'ecoute voyagé depuis quelques séances
et de bâtons mieux j'ai énormément
écouté de gens qui me semble bien plus
compétents que moi pour débattre et le
conseil numéro un le conseil le plus
récurrent
le conseil qui apparaît tout le temps
c'est d'écouter
il faut passer plus de temps à écouter
[Musique]
parce que c'est important de rebondir à
ce que dit vraiment l'autre et pas ceux
qu'on croit avoir compris en écoutant à
moitié car souvent ce que dit l'autre
c'est souvent des problèmes qui me sont
particuliers et du coup bah il faut
chercher à résoudre ces problèmes avant
tout il faut montrer qu'on se pose
pourtant que quelqu'un qui vient aider
non pas en tant qu'un adversaire
quelqu'un d'autre au risque forcément de
passer en mode soldats en mode ligue 1
et ce sera beaucoup plus difficile
ensuite de faire en sorte qu'ils prêtent
attention à des arguments qu'on voudra
avancer tout oui parce que en croire pis
tu ligne et c'est quelque chose que j'ai
lu dans plein d'autres livres seulement
des études sociologiques temps je
recommande pas mal
twitter il tire gaz de zeyneb touché qui
dans beaucoup beaucoup d' analyse ce qui
en ressort c'est que les personnes qui
se sont le plus radicalisés se sont
souvent radicalise et non pas à cause de
l'idéologie
les + parents vivent d'appartenir à une
communauté et il se trouve que certaines
communautés très radicales sont
finalement assez bienveillante envers
les leurs et peut-être bien plus que le
reste de la société
ce qui explique pourquoi certaines
personnes sont davantage séduits par ce
mouvement qui ne sont par d'autres
mouvements
en particulier si ces personnes se
retrouvent dans ces groupes là c'est que
souvent à la base il avait une crise
identitaire y avait un besoin un appel à
l'aide et du coup une meilleure façon de
des convertis rct des individus c'est
avant tout de chercher à résoudre leurs
problèmes à garantir leur réinsertion
finalement dans une autre communauté
moins radicale et ça ça commence par
écouter leurs problèmes par résoudre
leurs problèmes et ensuite vous pourrez
chercher à les convaincre mais souvent
l'étape la plus importante qu'elle plus
difficile ils avaient plus déficiente
après featuring c'est cette étape qui
consiste à venir en aide aux personnes
qui semblent qui se sont radicalisées
evry des femmes
[Applaudissements]
du coup le gros défi posé par christian
piccini c'est de développer de
l'empathie et de la compassion pour des
individus qui commettent des atrocités
et qui disent des choses ignobles et ça
c'est extrêmement difficile à mettre en
pratique c'est extrêmement difficile
mais je vous invite si vous n'êtes pas
quoique ça d'efficacité qu'à l'avenir
vaillance envers le côté opposé à de
l'efficacité je vous rencontre très
vivement d'aller voir l'hôtel x mais
christian fiche de piste située nieddu
lire son livre parce que visiblement la
bienveillance c'est dévastateur
mais pour y arriver il ya une étape
préalable qui est de sentir de la
compassion pour des gens qui font des
choses que l'on considère nous-mêmes
atroce donc typiquement si vous êtes
quelqu'un de droite
dites vous quand vous voyez quelqu'un
défendu les valeurs de gauche
essayez de ressentir cette empathie
cette compassion bienveillance envers
cette personne est devenu de lui venir
en aide
la même façon si vous êtes à gauche
si vous voyez quelqu'un de droite
s'exprimer avec des arguments de droit
essayez d'écouter et de sentir de la
compassion surtout si la personne est
très engagé c'est peut-être parce que
d'une certaine manière à la des
problèmes et que j'aimerai résoudre ces
problèmes et en montrant que vous voulez
vraiment lui venir en aide
ce sera du coup beaucoup plus facile de
l'année a vraiment réfléchir a par
exemple les arguments que vous voulez
poser
bref l'empathie notamment l'antipathie
mais aussi la bienveillance et la
compassion c'est finalement une des
choses les plus difficiles à mettre en
place dans des bâtons mieux à ressentir
pour l'autre dans des bateaux mieux mais
c'est peut-être le défi le plus
important à relever qui sera le plus
bénéfique à relever et du coup j'ai
envie de vous demander est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à relever le défi de la
compassion envers les personnes ils
disent commettent des actes
vous détestez